thank you mr speaker like many on these  benches i spent weeks and months  defending the prime minister  against often angry constituents  i've reminded them of his success in  delivering brexit  and many other things  but i expect my leaders  to shoulder the responsibility for the  actions they take  yesterday he did the opposite of that  so i'll remind him of a quotation  altogether too familiar to him of leo  amory to neville chamberlain you have  sat there too long for all the good you  have done in the name of god god  [Applause]  i must say to the right honourable  general i don't know what he's talking  about uh but what i think what i can  tell him i don't know what quotation  he's alluding to that he is afraid but  what i can tell him is that i and i  think i've told this house  repeatedly throughout this throughout  this pandemic i take full responsibility  for everything done in this government  and throughout the pandemic